[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العنود
ونفضل
سماح ايران لعمليه التفتيش في منشاتها
النوويه ويؤكد للعربيه ان لا خارطه طريق
حتى
في تصاعد للخلاف مع الكرملين قائد فغري
يعلن منع ممثل له من الدخول لمقر العمليه
العسكريه في اوكرانيا
يخالف رئيسي ويقر بتصميم الفتيات متهما
جناتا لم يسميهم بارتكاب هذه الجريمه
بعد ازمه المنطاد الولايات المتحده تتهم
الصين بالتجسس عليها عبر رافعات الموانئ
والاخيره تنفي
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه
اعلن مدير عام الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه رافاء الجروسسي عن سماح ايران
باستئناف التفتيش في منشاتها النوويه
مضيفا في رد على سؤال لمراسله العربيه ان
حل المشاكل العالقه مع طهران سيستغرق وقتا
مؤكدا انه لا توجد خارطه زمنيه للتعامل مع
الملف الايراني
يجب ان نتعلم من خبراتنا السابقه ومما
تعلمته فخارطه الطريق والمواعيد والتواريخ
يمكن ان لا تستجيب للواقع الذي نواجهه
نركز في الوقت الحالي على حل المشاكل
العالقه امامنا وبالطبع نتعامل مع خلفيه
قائمه على وقائع سياسيه وندرك انها لا
يمكن ان تستمر كذلك اود ان نحلها بحلول
الاسبوع المقبل لكن بالطبع ستستغرق وقتا
وفي رده على سؤال بشان تصريحات رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي الاخيره حول عدم
استهداف اي منشات ايرانيه اكد المدير
العام للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه انه
لم يتطرق لاي شيء غير عادي وان هناك
قرارات تتحدث عن عدم السماح باستهداف اي
مواقع نوويه
هناك عدد من القرارات لوكاله الطاقه
الذريه واخرى دوليه تتحدث عن عدم السماح
باستهداف اي مواقع نوويه وان الامر يعد
غير قانوني وخرقا للقوانين الدوليه لذا لم
اتطرق لاي شيء غير عادي او غير معروف
عربيه راقده بهنا ما حضرت هذا المؤتمر
الصحفي لرفائل الجروسي راغده اهلا وسهلا
بك لو توجز لنا ابرز ما اشتمل عليه هذا
المؤتمر الصحفي وهل بدا لك جروستي متشائما
ام متفائلا في مخص علاقه التعاون
المستقبليه مع ايران
اهلا بك يعني هو في الواقع رد على هذه
الجزئيه الاخيره قال بانه ليس متشائم وليس
متفائل ولكنه واقعي بمعنى يعني هو ايضا ما
اشار اليه عندما سالته عن المهل الزمنيه
بانه ليس هناك مهل زمنيه وبانه الايام
ربما المقبله ستحكم اذا كانت ايران فعلا
ستكون صادقه بوعدها للتعاون او بوعدها له
شخصيا الوعد الذي اعطاه اياها على ما يبدو
مسؤولون كبار واشار في المؤتمر الصحفي الى
انه في هذه الزياره التقى بالرئيس
الايراني وبوزير الخارجيه ووصفها يعني وصف
زيارته او لقاءه بالرئيس الايراني بانها
يعني كانت مهمه ومن هنا يبدو بانه انطباع
جروسيين بانه هذا هذه الزياره هذه المره
كانت مختلفه ويعني انطباعه بانه التعاون
الان سيكون تعاون بناء ولكن حتى الان يعني
ما زال ما حصل او نتيجه زيارته بالمزيد من
التعاون مع الوكاله واعطاء اجوبه حول
المواقع السريه
يعني نسبه تخصيب اليورانيوم المرتفعه التي
عثر المحققون او المفتشون على اثار منها
في منشات فوردو يعني هذا كله ينتظر تاكيد
في الايام المقبله لانه ايران حتى الان كل
ما اعطته هو بانها وعد بانها ستتعاون
ويعني هذا الوعد يعني يبدو بانه هذه المره
على خلاف المرات السابقه هو قال ايضا بانه
هناك يعني مجموعه من المفتشين دوليين او
مسؤولون من الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
ستتوجه الى طهران في الايام المقبله يعني
لبدء الحصول على اجوبه ويعني زياده هذا
التعاون ربما الملفت بانه ايران سمحت
بزياده
المراقبه داخل المنشاه الفرد وتحديدا هي
هذه المنشاه التي الان تثير القلق الاكبر
لانه بداخلها ايران عدلت من اليات او من
الالات التي تخصب اليورانيوم من دون ان
تبلغ الوكاله خلافا للتزاماتها وفي هذه
المنشاه ايضا تم العثور على اثار
اليورانيوم ال يعني التي تقترب من 90% في
الواقع وهذه نسبه تسمح بانتاج اسلحه نوئيه
طيب
راغده ان تكون هنالك تعهدات ايرانيه واضحه
طب السؤال المطروح ما هي الضمانات التي
بين يديه لانه الخارجيه الايرانيه اليوم
تحدثت بنفس تفاؤل كبير جدا عن هذه الزياره
وعن مستقبل التعاون مع الوكاله
بالفعل هناك اختلاف في التفسير يعني واضح
بانه المسؤولين الايرانيين يحاولون ربما
يعني هم ناقضوا الكثير من الكلام الذي كان
اعلنه روسي وكرره اليوم قالوا بانه لن
يكون هناك اعاده تثبيت لكاميرات مراقبه هو
واكد بانه هذا الامر سيحصل ولكن بحاجه الى
تفاصيل اضافيه يعني نتفق عليها وتحدث ايضا
عن انه سيكون هناك انه حصل على وعد بانه
سيكون هناك استجواب لاشخاص وزياره لمواقع
عسل المفتشون فيها على اثار تخصيب سري
ايضا ناقده فيها الايرانيون التفاؤل يعني
التشاؤم دراستي فسره بانه المسؤولون
الايرانيون ربما يتحدثون لاسباب سياسيه
داخليه
ويستهدفون جمهور معين وهو قال بانه ما
ياخذه من المسؤولين الايرانيين ياخذوه
بشكل مباشر منهم وليس ما يعني ينشر او
يتحدثون به لوسائل الاعلام ايرانيه ولكن
ذكرت يعني رغم انه هو قال بانه غير واثق
من انه الكلام الذي نشر في وسائل الاعلام
الايرانيه وما سمعه هو ولكن يعني يبقى
السؤال كما ذكرت هناك سؤال وعلامه استفهام
واضحه ما اذا يعني ما الذي تغير في هذه
الزياره ولماذا جروستي واثق هذه المره من
انها مختلفه يعني هو قال بانه واقعي
وينتظر يعني هذه الاجوبه لننتظر ونرى
مفادات العربيه راغده بهنام شكرا جزيلا لك
على كل هذه المتابعه
الى الحرف في اوكرانيا الان حيث قال قائد
مجموعه فاغنيل الروسيه الخاصه
انه تم منعه ممثله من الوصول الى مقر
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه لروسيا في
اوكرانيا وكان بريكوجين قد اشتكى في وقت
سابق من نقص الذخيره محذرا من انه اذا
اجبرت فاجنر على التراجع من بخموت ستنهار
هذه الجبهه باكملها على حد قوله
قبل ذلك اكد قائد مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه ان
قواته تشدد قبضتها الان على مدينه بالكامل
لكنه حذر من ان ضعف امدادات الذخيره قد
يؤدي الى انهيار الجبهه كما ذكرنا وقال
بريكوجين ان اجبار قوات فاجنر على
الانسحاب من باخمون يهدد المصالح الروسيه
مشيرا الى عدم تسلم معظم الذخيره التي
وعدت بها
اذا انسحبت شركه فان الجبهه ستنهار
باكملها فاجنر متراصه ويمكنها سحب الجيش
الاوكراني وتدميره مع عدم السماح لهم
بالتركيز على اجزاء اخرى من خط المواجهه
ايضا نحن نتقدم الى الامام ويجب على
الاخرين اتباعنا باي طريقه لحفظ ماء الوجه
ما يعني اعاده التعلم ويمكننا القيام بذلك
من المهم كسر الصوره النمطيه المقاتلون
يسالونني لماذا التاخير في امدادات
الذخيره التي تعهدت بها وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه يجب شرح ذلك في موسكو وايضا لماذا
لا يسمحون لنا بتجنيد عناصر جدد
تفقد وزير الدفاع الامريكي لويد اوستن
مقرا للقوات الامريكيه خلال زيارته للاردن
ضمن جولته في الشرق الاوسط حيث اكد اوستن
ان مدينه باخت لها قيمه رمزيه اكثر من
قيمتها الاستراتيجيه واشار الى ان سقوطها
لا يعني ان روسيا غيرت مجريات الحرب
لصالحها او انها تمثل تراجعا لاوكرانيا
واضاف ايضا انه لا يمكنه التوقع حاليا الى
اي مدى ستصمد امام الضربات الروسيه
في المقابل اعلنت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
التصدي لاكثر من 95 هجوما روسيا خلال
الاربع والعشرين ساعه الماضيه في خمس
مناطق وقالت في بيان الله ان القوات
الروسيه ما تزال تواصل هجماتها في محاور
كوبيان
وقد شنت 27 غاره جويه وسبعين هجوما
صاروخيا يوم امس
واشارت الاركان الاوكرانيه الى ان قواتها
الجويه شنت اثنتي عشره غاره على مواقع
تمركزات وانتشار القوات الروسيه
قال الرئيس الاوكراني انه اتفق مع القاده
العسكريين على استمرار عمليات الدفاع عن
ضخمه
وخلال اجتماع مع كبار القاده العسكريين
بحث
توزيع الاسلحه والمعدات بحسب العمليات على
الجبهات
[موسيقى]
قال تقرير لصحيفه ان روسيا تتردد في شراء
صواريخ باليستيه من ايران خشيه من تداعيات
هذه الخطوه على مجريات الحرب في اوكرانيا
خصوصا اذا دعم الغرب كييف بصواريخها
متطوره
رغم نقص الدخائر الموجهه بدقه وتعثر
انتاجها المحلي تتردد موسكو في شراء
صواريخ ايرانيه باليستيه خشيه تداعيات مثل
هذه الخطوه على الجبهه الاوكرانيه
ومكتسباتها حتى اللحظه هناك
الخشيه الروسيه من اللجوء الى ايران
تحكمها امكانيه اقدام الغربيين على تزويد
كييف بصواريخ بعيده المدى امر قد يقلب
موازين الحرب الدائره منذ اكثر من عام
ابرز مخاوف الروس ان تصل منظومه اتكمس الى
يد الاوكرانيين اذ هددت واشنطن في وقت
سابق بارسالها الى اوكرانيا منظومه
الصواريخ البالسيه اتاكمس يمكن ان يصل مدى
صواريخها الى 300 كم ما يعادل اربعه اضعاف
منظومه هاي مارس التي تلقتها كييف من
واشنطن المنظومه قادره على ضرب عمق
الاراضي التي سيطرت عليها روسيا في لوغانس
ودونيتسك ما قد يضع حرب موسكو في وضع صعب
الولايات المتحده كثفت مؤخرا تحذيراتها
بشان تعميق التعاون العسكري بين روسيا
وايران حيث تعتبر العلاقه بين طهران
وموسكو مقلقه للغايه لا سيما فيما يخص
الحرب الاوكرانيه
الحلفاء الغربيون يجدون هذه العلاقه مقلقه
للغايه ومن الواضح ان هذا الوضع يزعجنا
جميعا بشكل كبير فهو يمثل موضوعا للنقاش
داخل الحلف وسنواصل ارسال اشارات الى
ايران حول مخاطر دعمها لروسيا في حربها ضد
اوكرانيا وفقا لمسؤولين غربيين فان طهران
وموسكو بحثه امكانيه تبادل الاسلحه
الروسيه الحديثه مقابل صواريخ باليستيه
لكن المحادثات توقفت توقف محكوم بخطوات
حذره على ارض اصبح التقدم فيها ميلا يعد
انتصارا
س العربيه رائد الاغبر يتابع هذه الاحداث
عن كثب راد اهلا وسهلا بك اخر اخبار
المعارك في باخمت والجوار ولماذا رائد
عادت نغمه الخلافات بينر وموسكو الى
العالم مجددا
طالب مساء الخير بالفعل
دائما ما يطلق تصريحات بشكل يومي عن مسائل
مختلفه يعني للعلم عاد بريجوجن الى مسقط
راسه في مدينه سامبروسبورغ وهو يمشي في
الشارع فكتب خطابا بان الطرق في باخمت
اصلح من الطرق في مدينه سامبروسبورغ ويجب
تغيير عمده مدينه سام بطرسبرج وان عمال
النظافه يعرفون مهامهم اكثر من عمده مدينه
سان بطرسبرج هذه اشاره ودليل على ان
يفقيني قائد قوات فاغنر هو يعني يستطيع
التعليق على اي شيء دون اي
حاجه فبالفعل الدفاع الروسيه دعمت الجبهه
في باخموت باسلحه بالذخيره كما طلب منها
لكن ربما قوات فاجنر تطلب اكثر مما هو مما
تحتاجه المنطقه والمعركه في باخموت ونرى
الصراع ما بين الطرفين الدفاع الروسيه
والشركه الخاصه شركه فاجنر القتاليه
بالواقع يعني سيطرت قوات فاجنر فعلا على
مناطق واجزاء من مدينه
يبدو ان الاتصال انقطع مع رائد الاغبر لنا
عوده اليه في سياق هذه النشره في حال
جهوزه مجددا شكرا لك رائد كنت معنا من
دونات
نشاط الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
حالات تسمم جديده بين طالبات ايرانيات في
عشرات المدارس والسلطات تعتقل الصحفيا كشف
عن الكارثه
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشره الخامسه من
العربيه بالعوده الى من قطع من حديثي مع
مراسل العربيه في دونسك رائد الاغبر اهلا
وسهلا بكم مجددا بعد كنا نتحدث عن
الخلافات المتصاعده بين فاجنر وموسكو هل
هذه مجرد عمليه توزيع ادوار بمعنى ان
موسكو تريد الابتعاد ولو شكليا عن تصريحات
مؤسس فاجنر للتبرا لاحقا من كل الاعمال
التي تقوم بها فاجنر ربما
يعني طرح معقول جدا ربما يكون كذلك وربما
يكون هي هوائيه
الذي دائما ما يطلق تصريحات وانتقادات كما
اسلفت لك على مسائل مختلفه ليس فقط على
ميدان المعركه وما يحدث بالمعركه عموما في
محور باقي اعلنت ايضا ان قواته سيطرت على
اربعين في المئه من جغرافيا مساحه مدينه
باخمت النواحي الشماليه باكملها والشرقيه
باكملها واظهرت فيديوهات
للمصانع التي تسيطر عليها قوات فاجنر
وتحمل من منها يعني مصانع الكحول وتحمل
منها المشروبات لارسالها لمناطق لوغانست
في الثامن من اذار بمناسبه يوم المراه
العالمي كما انه قال بان المنطقه الشرقيه
جزئيا تم السيطره على يعني المناطق فيها
بالفعل ما زال الطريق السريع هو الوحيد
الذي يوصل الامدادات وتقول
المعلومات من المصدر انه تحت نيران
المدفعيه الروسيه وان هناك انسحابات من
المقاتلين الاوكرانيين بشكل فردي او على
شكل مجموعات صغيره ومنهم من يخلعون
بالذاتهم العسكريه ويخرجون كمدنيين هكذا
تصريحات من جانب المقاتلين الذين يعودون
الى دانيسك ويحدثون عن ما يرونه في
المعارك بالفعل
الجيش الاوكراني ما زال يقاوم حسب المصادر
ولم ينسحب من المدينه بشكل رسمي او بشكل
عام والمعارك تخلف مئات القتلى من الطرفين
هناك طالب من دون اسم مراسل العربي رائد
لاغبر شكرا جزيلا لك رائد على كل هذه
المتابعه
بعد تسمم الاف الطالبات بشكل متزامن في
عشرات المدارس بمدن ايرانيه مختلفه اعتبر
المرشد الايراني علي خمينائي هذه الحوادث
جريمه لا تغتفر مطالبا بمحاسبه جنات لم
يسميهم مع انزال اقصى العقوبه بهم
وقد اكدت احصاءات لقناه ايران انترناشونال
ان 80 مدرسه على الاقل تواجه ازمه تسمم
بسبب تعرض طالباتها لهجوم كيماوي وسط
اهمال بعض مسؤولي المدارس في تقديم
مساعدات لازمه التلميذات
حالات التسمم شملات محافظه طهران
وخوزيستان
و خراسان الرضاويه وفارس واصفهان واردبيل
وهمدان واذربيجان الشرقيه والغربيه وفي
السياق قالت رئيسه مركز الصحه غربي
الاهواز انه ظهرت على التلميذات اعراض مثل
احمرار الوجه والبشره وضيق التنفس
هذا واعتقلت السلطات الامنيه الايرانيه في
محافظه قم وسط ايران رئيسه تحرير موقع قوم
نيوز الاخباري الصحفيه علي بورت طبائي
بعدما كشف للمره الاولى عن حالات تسميم
للطالبات في المحافظه بحسب ما نشر موقع
اعتماد اونلاين الاصلاحي
هذا بعد نشر طبطبائي الذي ينشط في تويتر
باسم خيزران تقارير حول هذه الظاهره التي
بدات في الثلاثين من نوفمبر مع انتشار
حالات جديده لا سيما في المكان الاول الذي
ظهرت فيه
[موسيقى]
طالبه المتحدثه الرسميه باسم فوضيه الامم
المتحده الساميه لحقوق الانسان رافينا
شمدا سامي طالبت بتقصي الحقائق للتعرف على
مرتكبي هذه الهجمات الكيماويه ومعاقبتهم
خاصه وان قضيه التسمم المتسلسل للفتيات
ارتبطت بالجغرافيا السياسيه لايران وامتدت
الى عده مدن على حد تعبيرها
[موسيقى]
امهات يبكين على عتبات مدارس بناتهن
العليقات في المدارس الايرانيه صرخات
تتوالى لاخراجهن قبل اختناقهن بهواء مسموم
بمواده لا تزال مجهوله البعض منهن خرجنا
بحالات اعياء غير مفسره واصبحت الحافلات
تشارك سيارات الاسعاف في نقل المصابات الى
المستشفيات
ازمه تسمم تجتاح المدارس الايرانيه ليست
واحده او اثنتين بل 80 مدرسه للفتيات
بالتحديد المعارضه الايرانيه وجهت اصابع
الاتهام الى النظام في قضيه تسميم
الطالبات وصفه اياها بالعمل الاجرامي
لمزيد من المتابعه معي من عمان الدكتور
نبيل يعطون الصحفي المتخصص في الشان
الايراني دكتور نبيل اهلا وسهلا بك المرشد
الايراني علي خميني اعلن اليوم موقفا مما
يجري اعترف بوجود حالات تسمم للفتيات
واصفا ما يجري بالجريمه الكبرى داعيا الى
انزال اقصى العقوبات بالجنه ما رايك بهذا
الموقف
مساء الخير استاذ طالب يعني هنالك تضارب
في التصريحات ما بين من يعتبر هذه
هذا الحدث الجريمه كبرى وبين من يتحدث على
ان مؤامره خارجيه تستهدف النظام الايراني
هنالك طالب تضارب وارتباك في الموقف
الايراني الان يعني وسائل الاعلام
الايرانيه الناطقه باللغه الفارسيه انقسمت
الى قسمين قسم هو تحدث عن نظريه المؤامره
وان الغرب يريد نشر الفوضى وانه هنالك
منظمات ارهابيه مسؤوله عن نشر هذا الغاز
فيما اطلق عليه بالارهاب البيولوجي مسندا
ذلك الى مجاهدي خلق ومره الى اسرائيل
ومستذكرا في هذه
الفتره الحرجه فيما يجري في ايران ان
هنالك تنظيمات ارهابيه على غرار ما حدث في
الشيشان وفي افغانستان في الفترات
المتعلقه في العام 1989 ايضا وفي 96 من
حملات لما يسمى بالارهاب البيولوجي هي في
نهايه المطاف المرشد هو يريد ربما تهدئه
الشارع الايراني وابراز التضامن معه وخاصه
انه ما جرى ليس فقط في محافظه واحده بل
فيه 11 محافظه تم تصميم عدد كبير من
الطلاب والطالبات وحتى المدرسين بغاز يصعب
كشفه الان فبالتالي ربما هذا قد يدفع
حسب راي النظام الايراني ان هذه الهجمات
قد تدفع الى اثناء الشعب الايراني للخروج
الى
المحتجاجات وتظاهرات مجددا
وربما الهدف النهائي منه هو قمع هذه
الاحتجاجات كاحد الحلول في حين انه النظام
الايراني الرؤيه الاخرى بعدها تتحدث على
انه فعلا هنالك جهات متورطه داخل
النظام الايراني وهذا لمحت اليه عدد من
الصحف الاصلاحيه الايرانيه الامس واول من
امس
وربما تحدثت على انه لا يجوز ان دائما ان
نلقي باللوم على الخارج وان هنالك مؤامره
خارجيه تستهدف النظام الايراني في واقع
الامر ربما يعني
هذه الحاله من الارتباك في النظام
الايراني تعكس النظام الايراني عن التعافي
هل يمكن الجزم بوجود تناقض بين موقف
المرشد علي خميني وموقف الرئيس ابراهيم
رئيسي ام لا كلا الموقفين سواء سميت
بجريمه او مؤامره من اطراف خارجيه لتنفيذ
هذه الجريمه يصب في نفس الاطار
يعني
بداني اسميه انه ربما حديث المرشد لغايه
هذه اللحظه لم يتحدث عن مؤامره خارجيه
وهذه هي الاشكاليه الحقيقيه وربما انه هو
يريد
احراج الحكومه الايرانيه في هذا التوقيت
بالذات خاصه مع ربما اندلاء حاله احتجاجات
جديده
ومحاوله اظهار المرشد انه يقف الى جانب
الشعب الايراني على الرغم من انه يعني
احنا نستذكر انه النظام الايراني عاده ما
يعني هو المسؤول عن هكذا
مؤامرات او هكذا احداث ونحن ستذكر طالب في
27 اكتوبر من عام 2022 عندما اندلعت وتيره
الاحتجاجات قام
بافتعال ما يسمى بحادثه ارشاد شمران وهي
مسجد موجود في شيراز واتهام مسلح من داعش
بقتل 15 وجرح 17 شخص من مرتاديه هذا
فيما بعد اثبت انه الجناح حسين طائب
المحسوب على استخبارات الحرس الثوري
الايراني هو المسؤول عن ذلك وبالتالي
هنالك جهات موجوده داخل النظام الايراني
هي مستفيده من تاجيج الاوضاع الداخليه
خصوصا بعد الاقالات الكثيره لعدد مضادات
الاستخبارات وعدد من ضباط المخابرات
الايرانيه بسبب فشلهم في التعاطي مع هذه
الاحتجاجات هؤلاء لا يزال لديهم امتدادات
داخل مؤسسات الامنيه الايرانيه
والمستفيدين مما يسمى باعاده تاجيج الصراع
لجعل النظام الايراني يشعر بانه قد دفع
الثمن غاليا من خلال اقاله هؤلاء من عمان
الدكتور نبيل يعطوه الصحفي المتخصص في
الشان الايراني شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المشاركه
الى شان اخر الان من بعد حادثه المنطاد
الصيني التي اتهمت فيها واشنطن بالتجسس
تتزايد المخاوف الامريكيه الان جراء قدرات
الصين في التجسس على مصالحها الحيويه
مسؤولون امريكيون من الامن القومي
والبنتاجون قالوا انه من الممكن ان تمنح
الرافعات صينيه الصنع العامله في الموانئ
الامريكيه والتي من ضمنها موانئ عده
يستخدمها الجيش قد تمنح بيكين اداه تجسس
محتمله وفق صحيفه وولست جورنال الامريكيه
واوضح هؤلاء ان الرافعات التي تنتجها شركه
زيبي ام سي الصينيه تحوي اجهزه استشعار
متطوره تمكنها من تسجيل وتتبع مصدر وجهه
الحاويه وبالتالي فان المخاوف الامريكيه
من ان الصين قد تحصل على معلومات حول
المواد التي يتم شحنها داخل او خارج
البلاد تتزايد خصوصا دعم العمليات
العسكريه الامريكيه حول العالم
ممثل عن السفاره الصينيه في واشنطن وصف
المخاوف الاميركيه بشان الرافعات بانها
محاوله مدفوعه بجنون العظمه بغيت عرقله
التعاون التجاري والاقتصادي مع الصين
المخاوف بحسب مسؤولي الامن القومي
الامريكي تتوسع بشان سيطره الصين
المتزايده على الموانئ حول العالم من خلال
الاستثمارات الاستراتيجيه حيث تصنع بيكين
جميع حاويات الشحن الجديده في العالم
تقريبا وتتحكم في خدمه بيانات الشحن
معي من القاهره الان لمزيد من المتابعه
حول هذا الموضوع الصحفي المتخصص في الشان
الصينيه عامر الدمام استاذ عامر اهلا
وسهلا بك هل فعلا يمكن للاخذ بهذه
التقارير الامريكيه عن ان الرافعات
الصينيه في الموانئ يمكن ان تستخدم او
تستخدم لاغراض التجسس ام لا كل ما يجري هو
رهاب امريكي من اي شيء صيني يتزايد
ويتزايد في الايام القليله الماضيه
نعم بدايه تحياتي لحضرتك هو
رهاب مدروس وهو توسيع لدائره الشك في كل
ما ينتج بالصين في كل ما له علاقه بالصين
الولايات المتحده تدرس جيدا مفاصل
الاقتصاد الصيني بدات بحرب الكترونيه حرب
على رقائق الالكترونيه
لتعطيل برامج او لتعطيل تصنيع الهواتف
الذكيه وتعطيل تصنيع السيارات بدات ايضا
بحرب خاصه
الرافعات وشركه وشركه شنغها هذه الشركه
التي تعد احد اكبر احد اهم مفاصل الاقتصاد
الصيني خاصه وان هذه الشركه تصدر حوالي او
تستولي على 80% من حجم الرافعات في على
مستوى العالم هذه الشركه عنصر هام واساسي
في مبادره الحزام والطريق التي وخاصه
الطريق البحري التي تعتبره الصين احد اهم
المشاريع ويعتبره الرئيس الصيني هو
المشروع الاساسي بالنسبه له الولايات
المتحده تدرك جيدا من قبل عطلت شبكه الجيل
الخامس في الدول الحليفه لها
واوقفت عمل شركه خواوي في الكثير من الدول
اعتقد ان هذه التقارير وكما جرت العاده
تبدا الولايات المتحده بتقارير سريه ثم
بعد ذلك يعقب يعقبها تحركات في داخل
الولايات المتحده وبعد ذلك تحركات في
الدول
الحليفه للولايات المتحده اعتقد نحن نحن
الان بصدد بدايه لحرب خاصه بالسيطره على
الموانئ لقاء بحرب خاصه بضرب
المبادره الصينيه مبادره الحزام والطريق
واعتقد ان هذه هي البدايه بس استاذ عامر
يعني التقارير يجب ان تكون لديها مصداقيه
في الواقع يعني للعالم تاخذ بها طيب هذه
الرافعات موجوده وتعمل منذ عشرات السنين
الان استفاقت الاستخبارات الامريكيه على
انها تستخدم للتجسس طيب ما عدم ما بدا
بكل تاكيد هذه الرافعات تستخدم في
الولايات المتحده منذ عقدين تقريبا
الولايات المتحده اشترت في وسط الحرب
التجاريه في عهد ترامب اشترت في 2019
برافعات ب 320 مليون دولار من الصين
الولايات المتحده تعمل بهذه الرافعات منذ
فتره طويله ولذلك اعتقد ان
الحديث الان عن هذه الرافعات او الحديث
الان عن
الشكوك الامنيه بخصوص هذه الرافعات هو
شكوك او هو حديث مدفوع لاهداف اخرى خاصه
وان الولايات المتحده كانت ترغب في
البدايه ان يكون للصين او تنتج الصين
المعدات نفسها وان يكون الانظمه التشغيل
تكون من انتاج الولايات المتحده
الصين رفضت ذلك وهي تنتج الرافعات تنتج
ايضا انظمه التشغيل وهو الجزء الذي تقلق
منه او يثير قلق الولايات المتحده او الذي
تثيره الولايات المتحده في الوقت الحاضر
اعتقد ان هي هدف الهدف الاساسي هو الضرب
للتكنولوجيا الصينيه هو ضرب لهذا المفصل
في الصناعه الصينيه والا لماذا لم تكن
الادارات السابقه او تكن هذه
الرافعات مصدر تجسس في على مدار السنوات
الماضيه هل هناك تقارير فعليه او هناك
ادله على وجود اختار امنيه من هذه
الرافعات اعتقد ان المرحله المقبله سيكون
هناك فرد لعقوبات على هذه الشركه
وربما يكون محاوله ايضا
للدفع الحلفاء لعدم استيراد هذه الرافعات
خاصه وان هناك شركات اوروبيه تقوم
بنفس الانشطه ولكن هذه الشركه تعد
منتجاتها ارخص واعلى جوده نعم من القاهره
الصحفيه المتخصص في الشان الصينيه عامر
تمام شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
دخل ابو فذو ايران الى مؤتمر البلدان
الاقل نموا المنعقد في الدوحه في سجل مع
نظيره اليمنيه الذي وجه انتقادات لادعه
الى طهران خلال خطابه متهما اياها بارسال
هدايا الموت الى بلاده
ولكن في الانقلاب والحرب التي شنتها
المليشيات الحوثيه الارهابيه على الشعب
اليمنيشيات التي تدربت ومولت من النظام
الايراني
كماثيلاتها من الحركات الارهابيه
والعنصريه المعلنه التي انشتها ايران التي
انشدها ايران في الدول العربيه في غلط نشر
الفوضى وسيطره على المنطقه
كان الموقف الامومي الواضح في رفض انقلاب
الحوثيه الارهابيه واداره الممارسات
الايرانيه التقليديه المستمره في اليمن
والتي ما زالت تموله الى اليوم بارسال
هدايا الموت التي تقتل شعبنا عبر البحار
وعبر البر من طائرات مسيره
هنا كان هناك بعض
البيانات غير الهادفه التي تم الالقاء بها
في هذا
المؤتمر وهذا امر يؤسفنا ونحن بالنسبه
لشعب اليمن فنحن
نحن
نتمنى لكم
الرفاهيه او الاستقرار
اكدت القوات المسلحه الاردنيه المضيف
التعامل بكل قوه وحزم مع اي تهديد على
الحدود وذلك بعد الاشتباك مع مجموعه
المسلحه من الجانب السوري حاولت تهريب
المخدرات الى الاردن
وشدد الجيش الاردني في بيان على مواجهه
ايه مشاعر يراد بها تقويض وزعزعه امن
الوطن وترويع مواطني
الذي لفاصل نتابع بعده نشره الخامسه
اهلا بكم من جديد صرح المتحدث باسم حزب
جيده تركي المعارض في تركيا كورشاد زورلو
ان الحزبه قدم مقترحا جديدا بان يصبح رئيس
بلديه اسطنبول منصور يا وش ورئيس بلديه
انقره اكرم امام اوغلو نوابا لرئيس
الجمهوريه
يذكر ان رؤساء بلديات اكبر محافظتين
تركيتين ينتمون الى حزب الشعب الجمهوري
والذي يعد اكبر حزب معارض في تركيا
تركيا رجب طيب اردوغان على ابواب انتخابات
مرتقبه في حال فوزه فيها قد يتمدد حكمه
المستمر منذ 20 عاما لكن هناك ملفات
بمثابه حجر عثره خاصه اقتصاديا ابرزها
ارتفاع التضخم لمستوى هو الاعلى منذ 25
عاما حيث بلغ اكثر من 85% خلال اكتوبر
الماضي حاول الرئيس التركي الدفع باجراءات
تحفيزيه غير مسبوقه للخروج من الازمه
تتضمن دعم الطاقه ومضاعفه الحد الادنى
للاجور وزياده المعاشات التقاعديه ومنح
فرص لتقاعد اكثر من مليوني شخص
الا ان الزلزال شكل له تحديا اخر المعارضه
وبعض الاتراك يحملون حكومته مسؤوليه حجم
الكارثه بين استجابه بطيئه وملفات فساد
ففي السنوات العشرين الماضيه منحت السلطات
تسعه قرارات عفوا كان اخرها في عام 2018
لمبان تعتبر غير قانونيه بينما يرغب
الكثيرون في معرفه اين ذهبت اكثر من 38
مليار دولار تحصلت عليها الحكومه عبر
ضريبه الزلزال التي بدات تطبيقها في اعقاب
زلزال عام
1999 لكن التقديرات تشير الى ان خسائر
تركيا سترتفع بعد الزلزال فتكلفه اعاده
الاعمار ستكون باهظه الثمن وثقيله على
الاقتصاد التركي قد تصل الى 100 مليار
دولار
المعارضه التركيه كانت تراهن بثقل كارثه
الزلزال على حكومه اردوغان وتنبات بان
تكون القشه التي تكلفه خساره الانتخابات
لكن استطلاعات الراي تعكس حظوظ اردوغان
وتشير لفوزه بنسبه 49.8
افادت صحيفه البريطانيه ان بريطانيا
واستراليا ترغباني في عدم تاخر الركيزه
الثانيه لاتفاق اوكوس والذي يشمل التعاون
في مجالات الاسلحه التي تفوق سرعتها الصوت
وذلك عن الركيزه الاولى المتمثله في تزويد
استراليا بغواصات تعمل بالطاقه النوويه من
خلال تخفيف الاداره الامريكيه للقيود
المفروضه على تبادل التكنولوجيا والتقنيه
اجرت كوريا الجنوبيه والولايات المتحده
تدريبات جويه مشتركه استخدمت فيها قاذفات
استراتيجيه من طراز بيفتيتو القادره على
حمل اسلحه نوويه وذكرت وسائل اعلام ان
سيول تخشى من قيام بيون بيانغ بعمليات
استفزازيه عشيه اجراء تدريبات درع الحريه
المقرر اجراؤها للفتره من 13 الى 23 من
الشهر الجاري كما بدات سيول واشنطن
تدريبات جناح الاصدقاء في قاعده اوسانا
الجويه الامريكيه حيث شاركت فيها نحو عشر
طائرات ومقاتلات كوريه جنوبيه من طراز اف
15 واخرى هجوميه امريكيه من طراز اي 10
انتشرت في الاونه الاخيره توقعات لعلماء
ومتخصصين في الزلازل بحدوث هزات ارضيه في
بعض دول الشرق الاوسط وتحديدا في منطقه
الخليج
تبقى تلك التوقعات توقعات في نظر البعض
مجرد تكهنات في ظل الكثير من الدراسات
والابحاث التي تجرى في علم الزلازل سعود
الخلف والتفاصيل
رغم تنوع الدراسات والابحاث التي تجريها
المراكز البحثيه بشان الكوارث الطبيعيه
التي تشهدها الكره الارضيه لا تزال زلازل
هاجسا مؤرقا للعديد من الدول في العالم
الامر الذي دعا متخصصين في المنطقه
العربيه الى اجراء المزيد من البحوث
والدراسات ليس من المعقول ان تكون هناك
جهات او قوه لتحريك هذه
البلاطه او تسبب في الزلازل انما هي قد
يكون هناك اجتهادات علميه لكن في الواقع
كجيولوجيا كدراسه الزلازل وبراكين لا يمكن
لاحد ان يتحكم في حركه صخور
لالاف كيلومترات
وبساماكه عشرات الالاف من امتار ان تحركها
اي قوه كانت الا قوه الله سبحانه وتعالى
منطقه البحر الاحمر كانت نقطه الاختلاف
الذي دار بين المتخصصين منذ كارثه الزلازل
التي ضربت مناطق في تركيا وسوريا خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه حيث ذهب البعض الى ان
البحر الاحمر معرض لخطر الزلازل التي قد
تضرب بعض المدن المجاوره بحر احمر في
زلازل لكن تاثير علينا محدود لكن نتيجه
لشده الحراره
الموجوده في قاع وسط قاع البحر
فانها تعمل على اضمحلال الموجات الصادره
من الزلازل في وسط البحر الاحمر المدن
السعوديه على الرغم من تسجيل هزات ارضيه
محدوده خلال العقود الماضيه الا ان مراكز
الابحاث والتاريخ الزلزالي تؤكد بعد دول
الخليج عن انشطه الزلازل نحمد الله انا
لدي نا مساحه جيولوجيه وان هناك محطات
كثيره للرسل الزلزالي تتم متابعه جميع
الهزات مهما كانت صغيره لا يشعر بها
الانسان الى الزلازل الكبيره وبالتالي
تنتشر المحطات
والرصد الزلزالي موجود ونحن باذن الله
جزيره العرب بشكل عام والمملكه بشكل خاص
تقع ضمن الجزء المستقر من البلاط العربيه
يرى متخصصون ضروره التجديد خلال الفتره
المقبله على تطبيق المعايير المضاده
للزلازل في المباني وتصميمها بمواصفات
متوافقه وامنه من الهزات الارضيه اضافه
الى نشر الثقافه العامه بين الشعوب من جده
سعود الخلف العربي
قررت هيئه تنظيم وسائل الاعلام
الالكترونيه الباكستانيه حضر بث خطابات
رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان وذلك في
اعقاب خطاب القاه خان انتقد فيه حكومه
شهباز شريف والجيش القرار تضمن حظر كل
الخطب المسجله والمباشره لخان وذلك بسبب
ما وصفته الهيئه بالدعاءات خانه التي لا
اساس لها بحق السلطات ومؤسسات الدوله
وكان عمران خان قد اعلن في خطاب له رفضه
المثول امام محكمه باكستانيه للتحقيق في
قضيه فسد مؤكدا ان مثوله قد يمثل خطرا على
حياته
لا يوجد امن في المحاكم انهم يعلمون اني
تلقيت تهديدا لحياتي يستدعونني في قضايا
صغيره للغايه من محكمه الى اخرى
في مصر ما يزال الجدل مستمرا حول قضيه
تطبيق
من الاف المصريين الذين خسروا مدخرات تقدر
بمليارات الجنيهات التفاصيل في التقرير
التالي
عمر قاسم يعمل كعامل توصيل على دراجته
الناريه واحد من مئات الالاف من الذين
وقعوا ضحيه تطبيق هاك بول تلك المنصه التي
نجحت في الاستيلاء على سته مليارات جنيه
من مدخرات المصريين منذ انشائها منذ اكثر
من سته شهور قبل ان يتم اغلاقها ليتحول
حلم الثروه الى كابوس وعنوان لاشهر عمليه
نصب الكتروني انا رجل بطالب بفلوسي تمام
ان فلوسي ترجع لي ان انا يعني راجل شغال
على الله في يوميتي ما تجازيش ان انا اقعد
اسدد في الفلوس دي كلها اللي انا خسرتها
دي اسماء التي تعمل في مجال الهندسه كانت
ضحيه اخرى فالمنصه اوهمت عملائها بانها
تمتلك ماكينات للتعديل الخاص بالعملات
الرقميه ونجحت فعلا في توفير ارباح لفتره
قصيره انا مبلغي كان 31
في ناس تانيه مليون ونص وكده فالمبالغ مش
سهله واحده وتلاتين الف برضو احنا مش
جايبينها بسهوله يعني مش لاقيينهم في
الارض فهي الفكره احنا عاوزين حقنا يجي
فلوسنا بقى ترجع يتقبض عليهم كلهم ده اهم
حاجه حقنا يجي قوته الامن نجحت في القبض
على مجموعه من المتهمين اغلب الاموال تم
تحويلها للخارج بالعملات الاجنبيه النيابه
العامه امرت بفتح تحقيق موسع في القضيه قد
تحيل النيابه المتهمين الى محكمه بتهمه
الجنايات بتهمه توظيف الاموال وقد تحلهم
فقط الى محكمه الجنح
بجنحه النصب على المجني عليه
وايضا التهمه الثالثه وهيئه استخدام مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي
متخصصون في مجال التقنيه اكدوا استحاله
تمكن الحكومه واجهزتها في منع هذا النوع
من التطبيقات والمنصات التي تنتشر بشكل
كبير ده لازم يتم من خلال المنصه بالاتفاق
مع المنصه فالدوله تقدر تمنع ولكن لما
تعرف التطبيق بيعمل ايه فتطبيقات دي كل
يوم فالحاله الوحيد فيها هو الوعي بتاع
الشخص ما فيش حاجه اسمها هتكسب من الهواء
ولا فلوس مضاعفه من مجرد تعدين او من
عملات بحطها وارجع اخد من وراها مكسبول
سينضم الى قائمه عمليات النصب الشهيره
والتي تنجح اغلبها في الاستيلاء على اموال
المصريين الذين يخدعون باوهام الثراء
السريع احمد عثمان العربيه القاهره
نشط الخامسه المفصله انتهت اطيب التحيات
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
[موسيقى]